I used to collect pokemon cards until
one day I went to an Asian wedding and
some kids stole at all and that's when I
became an adult I had pokemon cards as a
kid but I just liked him for the
pictures I never played the game I spent
so much time collecting them and just to
one day have them be gone I was
horrified was kind of like beanie babies
whoever almost like one day these are
gonna be worth a bunch of money and so
in my mind like the little entrepreneur
in me was like keep these cards and then
I did this is so hurry a little bit to
think about Pokemon oh it does for sure
one time my brother and I bought UVO
cards off of ebay so I think that that
can maybe inform my expertise I'm
generally clueless about the value of
anything
I couldn't tell a $10 shirt from $150
shirt my name is Chris I'm with the
court TCG we're a retail card gaming
shop in Pasadena California we do a ton
of different collectible card games and
kind of have find expertise in valuing
specific cards we've had experience with
Pokemon since the existence of the card
game in the u.s. since 1999 within
collectible card games value comes from
supply and demand how many cards of that
specific card are available in the
market cards can be demanded by either
collectors or players of the game so
they look pretty different these three
Mewtwo's they're not like three of the
same card right away I recognized this
one like I had one of these and the fact
that I had it probably tells me that
it's not that expensive I am a Pokemon
collector I definitely have these two
I've never seen this one and it looks
really fancy these I don't recognize at
all but they're shinier than the other
one and usually the shinier ones are
more expensive so I think this cheapest
Mewtwo
I think there's like a 50 cent card a
ten dollar card a hundred bucks ten
dollars 255 Green trying to look at this
debt $10 $30 one hundred dollars two
hundred and fifty dollars three hundred
and I think this one's five hundred I
would never spend $30 on a card like why
from a demand perspective specific card
is used widely in tournament play that
can create a lot of demand for that
specific card $30 for a guard I mean I
guess five thousand which means I'm an
idiot what do people not like Pokemon
what's wrong with you people
two dollars been tricked I'm feeling
pretty confident I started out on the
right page I got Mewtwo right I was
very wrong I got one right I got one
right I got one
I mean how expensive could pokemon cards
really get
two of them looked almost exactly the
same this is tricky I have this Pikachu
though it's like before they made
Pikachu skinny I don't recognize this
one at all it doesn't even look like
Pikachu it tells me that it's polka - or
1999 which means it's vintage which
means this one is probably also vintage
but maybe not as vintage as this one I
feel like I'm in Mean Girls because I
keep saying vintage based on the last
one the 2017 one was valued like way
higher so I'm gonna say this once the
most expensive and then this will be the
middle and this will be the least
expensive ten cent card you can get in a
pack ten bucks or so I think this is
like $100 $5 $15 forty five $10 $15
forty dollars $2 $3 $30
this one's $0.50 I was very wrong
extremely wrong $50 I was close I guess
thirty I got all three right in this
group so I'm correct twice now I'm
feeling pretty good about myself I know
everything there is to know about
Pokemon cards this one was $5 that's
crazy they're the same card essentially
and this little piece of gold made this
like a forty five dollar difference when
they released this game in 1999 they
went around promoting this card so this
is a promotional item that came out of
Australia and that's why it has that
stump for the Australian polka torn it
goes for fifty dollars I love Charizard
if you liked anything other than
Charizard is because you're a contrarian
like me ah gag the chars out of course I
think chars arts pretty lame but I know
these are gonna be expensive because
like I feel like every little boy loved
jars already I started with like
Bulbasaur now I'm looking for the pocket
or is there a date on it this is the
trick these two look exactly the same
I'm gonna say this is the most expensive
and I guess these two are the lesser
expensive but I'm definitely missing
something because I don't think they're
the same price
oh I see edition 1 this means it's
probably from like the first pack ever
that's by really expensive then maybe
I'm just gonna say baseline they're all
$50 because they're holographic
Charizard cards so I'm gonna say 100
cheapest 200 second cheapest and then
500 for the first edition Charizard card
this one's gonna be like a straight-up
guess 15 bucks $30 card 200 bucks $1 $5
$50 $8.00 I think this one's 50 and I
think this one's a hundred because
that's what I value it in my heart so
starting at $20 is the cheapest
Charizard the most expensive Mewtwo
isn't that much more than that
whoa holy crap I was way wrong this is
$250 I definitely have one of these this
is crazy
how suppose $20 250 is the middle ground
how expensive this kit oh man this
thing's $2,000 okay I'm gonna put that
down that makes me like even not scared
to hold it I'm gonna take this with me
now this is a 1999 Charizard you could
get a used 1999 Toyota Camry for the
same price you guys I could get rich
quick I got the price wrong but I knew
it was the most expensive so I mean like
half a point the highest credit card
we've had is a graded nine shadowless
first edition Charizard valued about
seven or eight thousand dollars that is
a shocking spread of prices of Charizard
I cannot believe they got that expensive
and they look the same this is insane I
feel scared for whoever owns this
because it's made of paper and it could
get wet I think it's cool I've brings me
back to my childhood
I think Pokemon still cool I don't think
it's ever gonna stop because they're
probably like eight hundred of them now
probably more how do you stop someone
from just stamping edition one on a card
and then telling you it's worth $2,000
if I start today by the time my kids
have pokemon cards they'll be
billionaires so gotta be good
[Music]
[Music]